now introduce you to the concept of
exact equations and it's just another
method for solving a certain type of
differential equations let me write that
down exact
exact equations
equations before i show you an exact
equation is i'm just going to give you a
little bit of the building blocks just
so that when i later prove it or at
least give you the intuition behind it
you it doesn't you know seem like it's
coming out of the blue so let's say i
had some function of x and y and we'll
call it psi
just because that's what people tend to
use for these exact equations so psi is
a function of x and y
z is a function of x and y so you're
probably not familiar with taking
taking the chain rule onto partial
derivatives but i'll show it to you now
and i'll give you a little intuition
although i won't prove it so if i were
to take the derivative of this with
respect to x
where y is also a function of x i could
maybe i could also write this as
y
sorry not y psi
undo
so i could also write this as psi as
x
and y which is a function of x i could
write it just like that these are just
two different ways of writing the same
thing now if i were to take the
derivative of psi with respect to x
and these are just the building blocks
if i were to take the derivative of psi
with respect to x
it is equal to this is the chain rule
using partial derivatives and i won't
prove it but i'll give you the intuition
right here so this is going to be equal
to the partial
derivative of psi
with respect to x
plus
the partial derivative of psi
with respect to y
times d y d x
times d y d x and this should make a
little bit of intuition right i'm taking
you know i'm kind of taking the
derivative with respect to x and then
i'm and then if if you could say and i
know you can't because this partial with
respect to y and the d y they're two
different things but if these cancelled
out then you'd kind of have another
partial with respect to x and when you
were to if you were to kind of add them
up then you would get you know the full
derivative with respect to x that's not
even the intuition that's just to kind
of show you that even this should make a
little bit of intuitive sense now the
intuition here let's just say and i'm
not
let's just say zai and his i doesn't
always have to take this form but you
could you could use the same methodology
to to
take zai to kind of more complex
notations but let's say that psi
and i won't write this it's a function
of x and y we know it's a function of x
and y let's say it's equal to
f
some function of x
we'll call that f1 of x times some
function of y
and let's say there's a bunch of terms
like this
so there's n terms like this
plus all the way in the nth term is the
nth function of x
times the nth function
of y
i just define design like this just so i
can give you the intuition that when i
use implicit differentiation on this
when i take the derivative of this with
respect to x i actually get something
that looks just like that
so what's the derivative of psi with
respect to x the derivative of psi
with respect to x and this is just the
implicit differentiation that you
learned in your first or that you
hopefully learned in your first semester
calculus course that's equal we just do
the product rule right
so the first expression you take the
derivative of that with respect to x
well
that's just going to be
f
1 prime
of x
times the second function well that's
just g
1 of y
now you add that to the derivative of
the second function
times the first function so plus
f 1 of x that's just the first function
times the derivative of the second
function now the derivative of the
section function
it's going to be this function with
respect to y so you could write that as
g 1
prime of y
but of course we're doing the chain rule
so it's that times d y d x and you might
want to review the implicit
differentiation
of videos if this seems a little bit
foreign but this right here
what i just did
this expression right here
this is the derivative with respect to x
of this right and we have n terms like
that so if we keep adding them i'll do
them vertically down so plus and then
you'd have a bunch of them and then the
last one's going to look the same it's
just it's the nth function of x
so
f
n
prime of x
times the second function
g n of y
plus
the first function
f n
of x
times the derivative of the second
function the derivative of the second
function with respect to y is just
g prime
of y
times d y d x that's just the chain rule
d y
d x
now we have well now we have two n terms
we had n terms here right where each
term was a f of x times a g of y or f
one of x times g one of y and then all
the way to f n of x times g n of y now
we have for each of those we got two of
them when we did the product rule
if we
group the terms so if we group all the
terms that don't have a dydx on them
what do we get if we add all of these i
guess you could call them on the left
hand side
you get
i'm just rearranging it all equals
f
1 prime of x
times g 1 of y
plus f 2 g 2 all the way
to
f n
prime
sorry f n prime of x
g n of y that's just all of these added
up
plus plus all of these added up all of
the terms all of the terms that have the
dydx in them right so those are and i'll
do them in a different color let me
so all of these terms
which are going to be the different
color i'll do a different parentheses
plus
f1 of x
g1 prime of y
and i'll do the dydx later i'll
distribute it out plus and we have n
terms
plus
f n
of x
g
n prime of y and then all of these terms
are multiplied by d y
d x
now something looks interesting here
right we originally defined rsi
up here as as this right here but what
is this green term
well what we did is we took all of these
individual terms
and this green these green terms here
are just taking the derivative with
respect to just x on each of these terms
right because if you take the derivative
just with respect to x of this then the
function of y is just a constant right
if you were to take just the partial
derivative with respect to x
so if you take the partial derivative
with respect to x of this term you treat
a function of y as a constant so the
derivative of this would just be f prime
of x
g one of y right because g one of y is
just a constant and so forth and so on
all of these green terms you can view as
the partial derivative
of psi with respect to x we just we just
pretended like y is a constant and that
same logic
if you ignore this if you just look at
this part right here
what is this
we took psi
up here we treated the functions of x as
a constant
we treated the functions of x as a
constant and we just took the partial
derivative with respect to y and that's
why the primes are on all the g's and
then we multiply that times d y d x so
you could write this this is equal to
i'll do this green this could be this
green is the same thing as the partial
of psi
with respect to x
plus
what's this purple
this part of the purple
let me do a different color and a
magenta
this right here
is the partial
of psi
with respect to
y
and then times d y d x
so that's essentially all i wanted to
show you right now in this video because
i realize i'm almost running off time
that when you the chain rule when you're
taking with respect to one of the
variables
but both of the var but you know the the
function the second variable in the
function is also a function of x the
chain rule is this if
i is a function of x and y and i take
not a partial derivative i take the full
derivative of psi with respect to x it's
equal to the partial of psi with respect
to x plus the partial of psi with
respect to y
times dydx if y wasn't a function of x
or if y in no way
was if it was independent of x then d y
dx would be zero and this term would be
zero and then the derivative of psi with
respect to x would be just the partial
of psi with respect to x but anyway i
want you to i want you to just keep this
in mind
and i in this video i didn't prove it
but i hopefully gave you a little
intuition if i didn't confuse you and
we're going to use this property
in the next series of videos to
understand exact equations a little bit
more i realize in this video i just got
as far as as kind of giving you an
intuition here i haven't told you yet
what an exact equation is i will see you
in the next video